hello and welcome to episode 10 jet it's
almost like they can hear me saying hey
those titles you too complicated and
they make them unbelievably simple well
that's a very simple title to remember
uh and in some ways it kind of a simple
episode to remember to not especially um
I don't say not especially complex by me
it doesn't further the story too much
but it does sort of establish our you
know where our heroes are and where
serve other people are in terms of this
battle in this war this is the one where
they come across this village kind of
like The Lost Boys where it's a bunch of
kids and the trees and they're fighting
against the fire nation that has taken
over this realm and or this this part of
the land and you find a touch more about
the fire nation in that you do see oh
there are like families and people you
know it's sort of like you don't see
that in Star Wars either you don't see
like the family of the stormtroopers or
the people they bring on or anything I
like they give a little bit more debt to
it aside from fire nation bad
that's it except for one or two they're
the characters we're gonna make complex
no it's it's a war it's a bad on there
are gonna be civilians on both sides uh
so that's kind of nice this is one yet
they come across these kids in the tree
through web by a boy named jet who
Katara has the hots for and yeah
you kind of know where it's going where
Sokka is sort of he's getting a little
head of himself he's made a few mistakes
and this jet kid comes and is much
better than him and Sokka makes it clear
he wants to be the leader you know that
the leader of the three of them and
again here's a kid that's much better
much more athletic but his priorities
are little eschewed and they're a little
a little too intense he wants to wipe
out the Fire Nation and anything that
has to do with them even their families
even neighborhoods that do not partake
in you know the battle really well it
does seem kind of simple that there's a
few things I really like I like that
uh all three of the characters do not
have any interest of taking out the
civilians I think that's really cool I
it does show the extremes that some
people will go to and I think that even
though it doesn't completely for those
story as far as I know I see a lot of
people you know commenting saying it's
got to come back later so maybe it will
um but but the story for now that I see
it doesn't seem to be furthering it um
but it does establish that there's more
complexities going on here then um it
then a very basic you know good versus
evil and so forth um and I like that
these three characters are very much
they got their priorities in the right
place and I think for younger viewers
this is a really good chance to sort of
look into this a little bit more because
I am seeing more and more kids
programming does like to teach kind of
more different lessons than they used to
before you know and maybe that is a
common message now in kid shows again
not having seen many currently of does
wiping out you know it is the very idea
of are you with me or against me is that
the best mindset to go in with and
usually they lean towards no you know
it's never right to kill anybody you
know if you can avoid it and I like how
angles leans towards that too uh but the
the kid jet his side is is identifiable
um and I I don't know he sort of seemed
like sort of a lighter version of the
prince character um but again I'm not
against this episode because I think it
is good to make this clear to kids that
hey this isn't just good versus bad or
it's good versus bad there's some good
just one or two good characters you know
it's not that clear you know that you
know in times of battle and war you know
it's you go after the soldiers the
people who signed up to do this you
don't go after civilians um what I
really like about this episode
though is they go after this old man in
the in the opening and Sokka doesn't
like he teases a Fire Nation person but
he doesn't like that they're they're
going after him and they were gonna beat
him and stuff and Sokka actually stands
up for the guy uh so whatever it's just
a little leeway showing oh hey just kind
of bad and stuff that comes back I like
that it comes back to when Sokka has
actually leave the people out of the
village which you know I'll say to
myself well wait how would he do that
how would he convince them it's a and
the old man is there and I thought man
did that tie together perfectly like
that was really smart I love the way
that mesh together um I'm trying to
think that the the forest in this one
was pretty cool all the leaves were red
is sort of like permanent fall in this
uh which was also smart cos it shows
you're in Fire Nation territory as well
uh you know a couple of good jokes uh in
there um a lot of people are tell me
like a quick why you picking on Sokka so
much and stuff it I he's okay I mean I
don't dislike the character uh you know
it's just the company in his show in
general seems to be very sort of hit and
miss but seems to be getting better and
better and he seems to be very much the
comic foil for a lot of this but not
entirely he does it as I mentioned
before he has a lot of good strengths to
him as well and he does try hard and he
is very honorable and stuff like that
he's just also you know sometimes can be
egotistical and so forth and has the
funny one-liners uh sort of a typical
older sibling um so uh yeah I I don't
prom with the character thing on things
I do pretty much uh yeah I wish there's
more I can say about this episode it's
sort of just a very basic one okay not
that that sounds bad it's not very basic
on its own it actually has a real good
message for kids it's a good moral I
like that we see a little bit more what
the Fire Nation is sort of about a
little bit I mean just the fact that you
see they have families you know it just
sort of doesn't even dawn in your head
again it's like thinking what what do
the stormtroopers
what are their families like you know
you don't think of this stuff um so I
like that I like it gives a little bit
more it gives the villains a little bit
more of a personality outside of just
the top two or three their cats like
going after them it gives them a little
bit more of a life and when you do that
it just makes the world more believable
so I do like that and I think it's a
good message they're getting across to
UM didn't seem the furthest story too
much but again maybe don't come back
maybe we'll do all this iris stuff but
it's no good it's still a good episode
and I was glad I saw it yeah like I said
probably a short one today I couldn't
find a ton to say about this one but uh
you've heard me ramble on so much it's
probably relief to you so I will catch
you guys in the next one
take care